[Música]
hablamos de la salud que tanto me
importa a mí por supuesto también a
todos ustedes ya más romeros a la como
no si es la encargada de esta sección
más bienvenida feliz viernes el 10 de
octubre se conmemora el día mundial de
la salud mental un tema que en los
últimos años se ha visibilizado más
debido a esta pandemia 19 que tanto nos
afectó a todos más de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de salud mental sí me
parece importante empezar clarificando
algunos términos no para que todos
sepamos de qué estamos hablando al final
la salud mental es una mezcla entre
bienestar emocional bienestar social
también psicológico que nos permite
tomar decisiones relacionarnos
positivamente con nuestro entorno
manejar nuestras emociones y no es
exactamente lo mismo que las
enfermedades mentales las enfermedades
mentales ya requieren un diagnóstico a
veces son producto de una mala salud
mental y es muy importante recordar que
aproximadamente la mitad de la población
mundial en algún momento vivirá una
enfermedad de salud mental es un rango
muy amplio por lo poco que se habla de
este tipo de dolencias así es marc
impacto tiene entonces la pandemia del
coi 19 nuestra salud imagino que muchas
yo creo que yo lo sufrí usted no sé si
lo ha sufrido pero yo creo que la
mayoría de las personas que vivimos en
la pandemia pues todo el mundo sí pues
eso estoy va a decir yo creo que en
términos de salud mental por ejemplo
siento esa diferencia que decíamos
impacto a todos estamos hablando de
encierros de duelo directamente y claro
de perder la vida también que teníamos
que conocíamos hasta este momento no
hemos tenido que adaptarnos mucho y eso
siempre es difícil además también han
incrementado el número de enfermedades
mentales ya ha afectado de una manera
desproporcionada a los jóvenes han visto
sus centros educativos cerrados en un
momento muy importante del desarrollo
personal y precisamente de eso hablamos
con cristina meza ella psicóloga y
también es magíster en políticas
públicas de salud esto fue lo que nos
dijo el estudiante anteriores a la
pandemia han mostrado que el aislamiento
como tal puede generar
y negativos en los jóvenes porque porque
el estar en contacto con los padres es
fundamental para el desarrollo de una
identidad y una confirmación de aquella
personalidad y para la desarrollo
emocional en los jóvenes vamos a ver a
largo plazo que ha visto que el
aislamiento tiene consecuencias unos
años después en aquellos de aquellos
jóvenes que estuvieron aislados
socialmente durante cierto tiempo
en el futuro pueden desarrollar nuestros
trastornos
psicológicos pongamos cifras a esta
problemática gracias también a un
reciente informe de unicef publicado
esta semana uno de cada siete jóvenes
entre 10 y 19 años viven con una
enfermedad mental diagnosticada las
enfermedades mentales son uno de los
mayores riesgos a la hora de hablar de
suicidios y estamos diciendo que unicef
contabilizó 46 mil suicidios anuales de
jóvenes entre 10 y 19 años el suicidio
ya es una de las 5 principales causas de
muertes en el mundo en este rango de
edad y en europa por ejemplo es el
segundo y todo esto con sólo un 2% de
los presupuestos de salud destinados a
salud mental de media en todo el mundo
raúl como puedes ver es alarmante
durísimo además no es un niño de 12 años
cometiendo suicidio pues que fuerte debe
ser esos méritos de las personas que no
lo necesitan tienen un buen acceso a la
salud mental la respuesta corta es que
no en general o no de la manera que
debería ser hay datos de la organización
mundial de la salud que nos muestran
también como de difícil es acceder a
este tipo de servicios sólo la mitad de
los países en el mundo tienen planes
nacionales para abordar las
problemáticas de salud mental en sus
países y sólo un 25 por ciento incluyen
este tipo de servicios en sus sistemas
de atención primaria recordemos además
que durante la pandemia muchos de estos
servicios se ven interrumpidos o pasaron
a ser telemáticos muchos no se
consideraron por ejemplo servicios
esenciales exacto entonces eso hace que
las enfermedades que ya existen empeoren
y que las que no existían pues crezcan
marc ahora le pregunto y pues más bájate
a una pregunta de imagino que en los
países que tienen bajos ingresos pues la
situación fue mucho peor exacto ya como
como podemos suponer desigualdades que
afectan a todo también afectan la salud
mental se lo preguntamos también a
cristina meza y esto fue lo que nos dijo
la pandemia nos da dicho ver que las
desigualdades
están presentes y que se manifiestan
mucho más en enfermedad mental lo que
tiene que ver con el estatus
socioeconómico
incluye en gran parte en la salud mental
por el estrés que generan en las
personas además de estar relacionado con
menor ingreso económico
menor educación
de menor capacidad de acceso a los
sistemas de salud claro es decir estamos
hablando de población que vive en crisis
constante que vive sin ni siquiera tener
su propia vida asegurada enfermedades
que empeoran también toda la situación
en este caso pues las enfermedades de
salud mental sólo hacen que agravar si
además no reciben la atención que
necesitan como estábamos viendo esto
todavía es peor en los países de
ingresos bajos donde entre el 75% y el
85% de las enfermedades mentales no
reciben tratamiento aquí ven algunos
ejemplos- por ejemplo la depresión sólo
el 50 por ciento de los casos reciben el
tratamiento en el caso de la
esquizofrenia sólo un tercio de los
casos diagnosticados son algunos
ejemplos pero pues son muchísimos más y
nos hacen ver raúl que al final esto es
una crisis de salud pública que no está
siendo atendida y que también hay muchos
estudios y muchos artículos en revistas
y prensa especializada en salud diciendo
que la depresión va a aumentar en los
próximos años muchísimas gracias marx
por toda la información feliz viernes de
fin de semana nos vemos